de vacunación en los suburbios de parís
estaba listo para abrir el lunes pero ya
no será posible decir te preparamos todo
en 72 horas estábamos listos para una
apertura el primero de febrero y luego
las autoridades me informaron hace unos
días que por falta de dosis no era
posible abrir
los problemas de suministro están
afectando a tres regiones de francia la
agencia de salud de hoy de fans dijo que
todas las primeras citas para vacunarse
que organizó para principios de febrero
se retrasarían un mes y se
reprogramarían para la primera semana de
marzo las otras regiones están
experimentando retrasos similares para
aquellos que ya han recibido la primera
dosis de la vacuna del cob y sus citas
para la segunda inyección todavía se
mantienen eso incluye a los que corren
mayor riesgo residentes y empleados en
hogares de ancianos pero aquellos que no
hayan recibido la primera dosis tendrán
que esperar y eso incluye a los mayores
de 75 años y a los trabajadores de la
salud que tenían citas programadas en
las próximas semanas si hubiera
preferido vacunarme antes para no tener
que preocuparme así que ahora estamos a
su merced
francia depende de la unión europea para
su suministro desde que el bloque
decidió asegurar las dosis
colectivamente otros países de la unión
europea también han tenido problemas con
sus programas de vacunación esta semana
el ministerio de salud francés dijo que
se habían administrado más de un millón
de primeras dosis y poco más de seis mil
personas habían recibido sus segundas
inyecciones